das ist das leckerste Sandwich dass ich
kenne
und das heißt BLT und hier ist alles was
wir brauchen Bacon letics tomatoes und
die eigentliche Hauptzutat Mayonnaise
wir nehmen unseren Bacon und packen ihn
in den Ofen der ist gerade angemacht 200
Grad wir nehmen uns schöne weiche
Tomaten und schneiden dünne Scheiben
daraus ganz ganz ganz wichtig
tomatensalzen jetzt nehmen wir uns ein
paar Salatblätter waschen Sie und von
den nehmen wir nur den knackigen Teil
das Essen wir natürlich auch unser Bacon
ist knusprig und der Ofen warm hier lege
ich hier auch ein bisschen Zewa und wir
nutzen das Gute Bacon Fett um unseren
Toast zu toasten und so einfach wieder
in den Ofen bei 200 Grad nach 10 Minuten
ist unser Toast fertig getoastet
knusprig und wir können belegen zu
allererst einmal Mayonnaise nicht zu
knapp dann ein Bett aus knusprigem Salat
es folgen die Tomaten schön dünn boah
jetzt schon so saftig und natürlich der
Bacon Mario auf die Oberseite Deckel
drauf und das Wichtigste in Dreiecke
schneiden
guckt euch das an